there's a viral tick tocker
who has a message
to white people you know very often
these these ideas critical race Theory
and all of the modern woke ideologies
they they present themselves as so
complicated oh there's just so it's
problematic and complicated and you need
to have read all of these really
esoteric thinkers to understand the
meaning of well not this lady this lady
has a very clear message
on race
I'm feeling spicy so here's my hot take
of the day all white people are racist
every single last one of them
only meant to say like every single
individual white person if I talk to you
you would have some kind of racist
ideology I'm saying that as a white
person you uphold a system of racism by
literally just being white I believe if
you're not spending your literal entire
life dismantling racism then you're
contributing to its continuation and
people get so closer
literal entire life not figurative
entire life literal entire life so if
you don't spend every
single moment of your whole life
if you ever sleep
if you ever blink
and are not in that moment fighting
racism you're a terrible racist by
virtue of being a white person which
which brings you back to the first point
you made which is all white people
all the time are evil terrible racists
let's keep going
like I say like
they're like yes you're racist like okay
we've established that now what are you
gonna do to change it racism refers to
power
nothing I guess
nothing I guess if that's if that's the
premise
that all white people all the time by
virtue of being white are racist
then okay
I thought maybe there was something I
could do to change it I thought maybe
there was some way that I could improve
or practice virtue or do good things but
I can't even though she's saying it did
what are you gonna do to change it she
tells you for the first part of the
video there's nothing you can do to
change it you are a white person you are
evil you are useless you are hopeless
everything you do by virtue of who you
are is evil so I guess the only the only
possible answer to that
if you accept that premise is
okay
guess I'm a racist then whatever
whatever okay then I'll stop caring all
right I just won't worry about it
anymore
it's a great meme of the way that uh
conservative thought has evolved in just
the last 10 years
the first the first part of it is the
Tea Party guys it's hey let me tell you
about your constitutional rights we're
all countrymen let's just get back to
basics and the founding fathers and cut
taxes and okay and the second one that's
more the Maga movement they say hey
there's some real problems here I mean
we're all still Americans we all still
love each other and you know but you
guys got to stop being so tough on us
and we're gonna have some rights and
maybe we shouldn't totally have open
borders and and then the last panel is
just this guy he's got five o'clock
shadow he's just
seen a lot you know smoking a cigarette
he says oh okay I'm evil I guess all
right I'm racist and phobic and cool
whatever and oh yeah you're gonna oh
you're gonna you're gonna call me all
sorts of mean names whatever bro LOL
fine and it just doesn't affect him
anymore
that's the only rational response to
this video I remember when I was in
college Ann Coulter came to visit and
she said that when a liberal calls you a
racist you know you've won the argument
that's how I feel I mean they'll do it
to anybody often they'll do it to black
people if they don't know that those
conservatives are black I always go back
to this example of David Webb who's a
black conservative radio host and some
liberal caller didn't know what he
looked like and just the minute he
started to win the argument she just
accused him of white privilege and he
just laughed I'd say okay that's fine
we're all racist okay yeah cool fine
whatever were the powerful race in a
society then your racist like I just
don't understand why it's so taboo let's
talk about it so that we can work
together we're never gonna get anywhere
and people won't just acknowledge it in
the first place I guess we're not
getting anywhere I guess you're right
you're saying we can't get anywhere so
okay
so it's obviously not Tad but it's not
taboo to say white people are racist or
evil or terrible in fact it's encouraged
by the society
white people and to some degree Asians
it's the only race that you can legally
discriminate against and that you're
encouraged to insult so
okay
yeah that's not taboo you're right
let's just talk yeah okay sure you said
it you're right yeah we're all the worst
people in the world uh-huh can't there's
nothing we can do to change it all right
whatever
next I don't know swipe up okay what's
the next Tick Tock little literally here
what is the next Tick Tock is from
from Sam Harris the liberal atheist
attacking uh the one of the black faces
of white supremacy our friend Candace
Owens we're swimming in a sea of
misinformation where you've got people
who are moving the opinions of millions
of others
who who should not have an opinion on
these topics like there's no put a pause
there
Sam Harris
Sam Harris best known
for
for trying to convince edgy 13 year olds
not to believe in God Sam that's what
he's known for he's known as one of the
four new atheists which was this kind of
contrived publishing movement in the
mid-2000s
Sam Harris who I don't mean to insult
him or anything like that but not
you know not not the highest finest
intellectual in the world okay he's just
a he was a sort of a publishing thing
and he had this really silly idea and
it's one of the and it's probably the
single dumbest idea anybody can have in
the world which is that God does not
exist and he has the audacity to tell
people that they should not have an
opinion
Sam Harris the great liberal the great
liberal we hear it all out we're
pro-free speech so certain people
shouldn't have an opinion who are those
people
there is no scenario in which you should
be getting your opinion about vaccine
safety or or climate change or
the war in Ukraine or anything else that
we might want to talk about from
Candace Owens right it's just like it
like like she she's not a relevant
expert on any of those topics and what's
more she doesn't seem to care
he said a few true things there
he said two true things a Candace Owens
is not a relative expert
or not a relevant expert that's true she
doesn't have a white lab coach she
doesn't have a medical degree she didn't
study epidemiology at Johns Hopkins
that's true
and it's also true that she doesn't care
she's going to give her opinion whether
Sam Harris wants her to or not
there's something here that Sam Harris
missed
which is that
when it comes to vaccine safety
it comes to the efficacy of the covid
vaccine
Candace Owens was right
and all of the relevant experts were
wrong
it's this really weird fact
that on the pressing
public matters
regular people
are often right
and the relevant experts with all the
special credentials who Sam Harris gives
a stamp of approval to
are frequently if not always wrong
so if we're going to take away the
ability of either of these groups to
have an opinion that is public
wouldn't it make more sense to take away
Dr fauci's platform wouldn't it make
more sense to take away the platform of
the CDC or the who which totally botched
covet
wouldn't it make sense to take away the
platform of Sam Harris who's wrong about
pretty much everything
is if I'm just judging by who's right
and who's wrong
that's true you know I'm giving I have
this debate it's still scheduled we'll
see if the administration cancels it I
have a debate on transgenderism with
with a transgender scholar a supposedly
distinguished Professor with three
degrees from Harvard and half a dozen
honorary doctorates and dozens of
academic Publications who is a man who
identifies as a woman and he calls
himself Deirdre and his real name is
Donald and he's supposedly this
distinguished scholar he's got all of
these degrees and credentials and he's
been tweeting about our debate and the
only points that he's really made about
the debate he wants the debate to go on
and he said Knowles is a fascist Knowles
is a fascist he's he used the phrase he
said I'm an anti-jesus Catholic
so I guess cat he's a physical paleon
that's really talk about
you know glass houses but he's accusing
the Catholics I guess of being
anti-jesus I don't know that's he's the
expert he's the he's the distinguished
scholar so you're a fascist you're mean
you're an evil
I I haven't said anything like that at
all I've only said relatively
complimentary things about him
I don't I'm not I'm not some
distinguished scholar I don't have any
particularly Advanced degree
that's the way it goes and I happen to
be right on the question men are men and
women are women and you know who else is
right every normal person who has ever
lived for all of human history
are all right
it takes multiple degrees from Harvard
not to know what a woman is
ask Justice katanji Jackson the rest of
the show continues now you do not want
to miss it
uh you can become a member right now at
dailywire.com using promo code Knowles
at checkout you will get two months free
on all annual plans Mr Davies has lots
of secret special fun things planned for
the
inner circle of the members block we'll
see over there
[Music]
foreign